hi do you like adult toys because i do
same i have one in the room
anyways adam and eve is our sponsor and
we love them so much adam and eve is the
number one trusted source
for adult toys uh they've been in
business for almost
50 years really i didn't know theirs of
adult toys that's a lot of
years hairs so your hairs your hairs
they have 24 7 customer support in case
your
toy explodes
they don't they don't you could stress
them out though yeah
they have high quality stuff so you'll
probably never call them they won't
explode unless
it's specifically made to explode if
you're into that
they also have 90 day no hassle returns
and very discreet packaging
uh to 20 of their profit goes to help
fight the spread of hiv around the world
also so that's really cool
um visit adamandeve.com and use the code
mood for
50 off one item plus free shipping in
the us
and canada some exclusions apply again
visit adamandeve.com and use the code
mood for 50 off one item
plus free shipping in the us and canada
america's hat imagine handling the
returned sex
toys just like used butt plugs
what a job i think that's an essential
job i think they've done it so many
times they're just like
they're flipping through this one guy
that really likes that he's like
right away welcome to big mood we're
happy to have you here today we have a
special guest a very special guest
he's super handsome very sexy please
get two turned on by him you're happy
married okay
she's take it ladies i would like to
also be introduced as a britney spears
uh
aficionado a breed and britney spears
free thinker and truther
free britney truther britney spears free
thinker and truther
an expert stephen paul green hi
everybody i'm a big britney spears fan
big expert on britney spears
so what is it what's what is uh no one
else is in the room
are we just invisible to you no this is
tiff and that's gina
oh yeah let's let's introduce ourselves
for those audio listeners out there i'm
nikki limo
i'm tiff and i'm gina and we
are big moves that's the corniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen are we the power rangers
it's just the same
horrifying we are these big moves right
big oh my god come on steve
yuck man i like that we are
she's crazy you sound like a weird boy
band good lord free steve
exactly so you guys want to know about
britney spears or what [ __ ] do
yeah okay so what do you guys know about
britney spears she's under a
conservatory ship yeah conservator
her dad so her dad controls everything
from her money or spending her work her
contact to the outside world everything
basically her whole entire life is
under conservatorship yeah she also had
a few hit singles
very true less known for that though
yeah yeah
so yeah so brittany's been under this
conservative tour ship since like 2009
because she went through this she had
like a very public as you guys know 2007
quote unquote mental breakdown which the
older i get
i i get it i understand and also um
like people are looking at it as though
she was just a normal person that had a
breakdown like imagine being followed by
paparazzi's
because she was in the mickey mouse club
too so i don't know about paparazzi back
then but still like she's been
yeah the mouseketeer
probably not but also like i mean there
are probably some weird
[ __ ] going on with the disney stuff and
the adults and the children
every aspect of her life was controlled
especially disney
controls a lot like a lot of stuff um
you know if you sign on
there was a period of time where both
disney and dick nickelodeon were doing
this thing
nickelodeon nickelodeon jesus christ
and nickelodeon disney and nickelodeon
um but they were doing this thing where
they wanted to create
stars so they would you had a show okay
and then you would do it
yeah exactly so you were like a musical
star an actor and it was all under like
one contract
and they controlled like everything they
controlled your social media they
controlled everything
so um imagine like yeah she was in the
mickey mouse club
and then growing up just having like her
image completely controlled
she's over sexualized at such a young
age because that um
hit me baby one more time girl she was
16. i was 16
yeah she was sitting in that school girl
was i so it was okay
yeah well you were younger than that
yeah exactly yeah i was like oh thank
god
yeah so she influenced a lot of 12 year
olds because that's when we all
found out about her too well you guys
are even younger than that yeah
but that's when she exploded and like
then all these younger
kids because if you're 16 then you're
influencing you know much younger than
you
started getting like way more sexual
like wanting to dress more that's so
true
i remember being nine years old in my
bedroom and that's when
uh the uh i'm a sled oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
slave for you yeah nine for that whoa
that was nine when that came out
and or maybe eleven now between nine and
eleven i forgot
but i remember being a child though and
like trying to do her
yeah dance and i i was like in the
in front of the mirror and then i would
actually tie my shirt up so
my belly was all exposed trying to
emulate
brittany yeah in that music video nine
yeah
yeah that was on trl yeah total request
live carson daly so if you think about
it
when because so britney spears was
always like under her parents right and
then she's like in the disney system for
a while and then
she comes out of that and she's
basically an international superstar
yeah when was brittany ever free
yeah yeah ever and if you guys would
just want to take a moment to think
about that
when she was four she had a regular
childhood i mean she never got to even
be an adult who's in charge of her own
finances like doing her own kind of
thing
because because she had it all taken
from her was it like a stage mom
situation i didn't read a lot about her
mom so i
i'm assuming not well i don't know the
yeah that's kind of what's going on i
know they came from like more of a
uh like poor lower income
background and then they like went to
california to like try
well her sister was a nickelodeon
later later yeah later and then she she
ended up becoming a teen mom too
and then like she got really killed for
that like crazy but it's just like
there's a lot of stuff going on yeah
so yeah a lot of the time when people
talk about this we go from her public
breakdown right like that's
that's what everyone says it's a public
breakdown but really what did she do
right she
went to a a barber shop she had her hair
barber shop she had her head shaved in
the middle of the night well it's
because her extensions were
like digging into her scalp and she was
just like i'm [ __ ] tired of it and so
they they had somebody in there
obviously opening the blinds because
they took the shot from outside
yeah so why if it's this thing that
she's doing that she wants to keep so
private why did she open the blinds for
it like it like
there's a lot to this because if you've
been to her instagram at all
yeah there's a lot of things there where
it looks like that's kind of like how
this
came up is that people were noticing
that her instagram
changed because if you go back a few
years ago her instagram was not as crazy
like she's still
kind of controlled and stuff but like
she's not
as out of it like as she has changed
um like she used to have more of a
natural delivery like she would talk to
the camera and she'd be like hey guys
it's me brittany and i'm doing this or
like oh these are my outfits that i
picked today
but now if you go to her instagram it's
just like her like staring at the camera
doing um
yeah weird spins tell that no for sure
there's a
a drastic difference but i i guess i'm
like conspiracy land like what do you
think changed
like why is she now more outwardly
coming
out like she is definitely lost
well there's theories because we don't
know right so it's like you know is it
medication
is it that she's going through something
even more serious mental wise like is it
or is it even just what a lot of people
think which is that she's trying to
reach out for help like she's
she's battled with her father to have
him removed
as her sole conservator and they ended
up getting this other guy to be a
conservator with him
to help manage her finances and both of
those cats are getting
hundreds of thousands his name is wallet
yeah his name is
his name's wallet and he's getting her
money wow way right talk about born into
it
but who is he exactly like a man he's a
financial guy he's a
yeah he's a lawyer i thought but um
let's start from the beginning like if
you go back in the timeline
like when do you think that she started
being controlled by everything or what
led to her breakdown
i don't think she really broke down
that's what i think is [ __ ] about
all this stuff
i think that uh when everyone says that
they
uh that dave chappelle broke down or
whatever what did he do he just [ __ ]
quit a contract and left
like it's not he had a mental breakdown
everyone says if you get out of the
limelight you're having a mental
breakdown because everybody's over your
head you're having a breakdown same
[ __ ] happened just recently to tiffany
haddish she just had enough of her hair
she wanted to go bald
she did it and people were like you're
crazy now
yeah so i think that the terminology
breakdown is stupid for that i think
that
which what actually happened to her is
she had a problem
like with some kind of mental issue or
something with drugs
that we don't know about but she ended
up because she had to go to rehab right
like she went to rehab i think twice so
something
happened that facilitated that a lot of
people think it was drugs
and she ended up having um
i mean recently her her own kids filed
for
a separation emancipation yeah from
from the conservatorship for for they
they got a restraining order against um
her dad oh right for abuse of or
whatever like some kind of a
jesus so yeah there's so much to this
stuff that gets lost when people just
say she went crazy and this should have
happened
like it's not so simple to just look at
her and go
she's everything that's wrong with it
she obviously is mentally [ __ ] up and
they have to control her finances or
she's going to spend all 59 million
how did this come to be because i feel
like if we're starting from the
beginning because we're assuming a lot
we're assuming a lot of people have been
following the story we're assuming that
people have seen her instagram we're
assuming that they they know what we're
talking about
so starting from the beginning britney
spears she became this mega superstar
from um you know her music
and then um she got like
so famous and you could tell like her
her the fame was kind of
she's been reading her life as a song
yeah
yeah and and she would like talk about
and you could see like
the tabloids at that time she would go
on vacation and they would have like
pictures of her from a helicopter that
they took of her laying out and they
would be like look how fat britney got
like she got so
she gained so much weight oh she's
struggling she's having a problem
so you have all these people commenting
on your life non-stop 24 7.
and she came out with like a piece of me
you know like and that kind of sums it
up where
everybody just seems to want a piece of
her and then um
she goes she has her kids and her and
kevin are having
a tough time right after the big justin
timberlake breakup
yeah so fans are hating on her because
of the justin timberlake breakup like
cause the rumor was that she cheated on
him and that's why crime crimea river
came out
yeah great song yeah and he had another
song that was like
but you didn't say you're sorry do you
know that song
oh i was about to sound exactly like him
that was amazing thank you yeah i try i
mean
it's a gift even with the kevin
federline thing didn't they get married
in a really
weird rushed way too and it was like
scandal
i don't know if i don't know enough
about the scandal part but i just
remember they wore
track suits like they got ready and then
if you remember she
also married like her childhood friend
a weekend within 24 hours
wow yeah yeah i forgot about that yeah i
don't remember that at all yeah so then
she
um got caught like with her
kids on her lap while she was driving
and people were just calling her a bad
mom and they were just like really
coming down on her
and um and then she just goes
quote-unquote crazy
and um shaves her head she starts
wearing wigs and talking in accents and
um just in my opinion it's like a [ __ ]
you
like let me just live because she's
never got to like live
her life like she's always very
controlled in every aspect
and then i'm just hanging out with
people though people do accents and [ __ ]
like how is that part of her mental
breakdown she's an artist she's a
creative artist
like people just like to [ __ ] around
nobody said madonna's mentally broken
down when she did the face
she was british for a while yeah she
lived there and she's like oh this
sounds so much nicer to say things like
this
oh yes remember when she converted to
united kingdomism
man i don't know anymore i remember she
was into cabal of whatever the hell yeah
she's in kabbalah yeah
yeah yeah so but they did call her crazy
they used that
as proof that she wasn't capable of
handling her finances and
her kids and her you know mental states
so that that's how
a conservatorship was put in place
because it was temporary
temporary yes exactly and he had it he
had it extended by the end of the year
i think it was 2009. so it was just
supposed to be for a little bit
then he gets it extended and then now
here it is we're 20 20 we're still
talking about it's been 11 years right
and so a lot of the fans are like wait
so she could
go on tour come out with all these
albums um
have a vegas residency and perform every
night
but she can't handle anything else in
her life like how is she mentally
available
to do all the work but not mentally
available
to have the money from her work right
right and they
they argue her dad and the other guy
argued that they're just looking out for
her best interests
like they even disclosed that she had
like 400 000
of living expenses or something last
year like she's living comfortably kind
of kind of a
statement but what's messed up is it was
supposed to be temporary now it's been
extended indefinitely and she's not in
control of her own life
she can't even make it even like asking
the courts like can i please
yeah whoever drafted and passed that
contract with indefinite language is
really
[ __ ] up well the idea behind that is
supposed to be there for people who are
mentally incapacitated in some way
that's what they claim
right so they're basically having to
prove that she
is not um right and so they have a
financial
interest to do so as well so it's super
weird of course
that this can go on and nobody seems to
care
except for britney fans now anything
pretty much her caretaker fun fact my
friend
her her personal trainer boyfriend is
friends with my friend they were in a
frat
together and they like they follow each
other on instagram and everything and
it's pretty much well known that that
guy's just pretty much
her like not caretaker but her wrangler
or her paid for boyfriend yeah yeah like
some tom cruise [ __ ] gym guy
he's like uh he's like a buff like yeah
i thought is he a dancer or i have no
idea like her trainer or whatever yeah
trainer yeah
i just know he like works out a lot
there's also
conspiracies and her because i i read
the comments under her post too and a
lot of people are
claiming that they're just like how are
people not noticing that this isn't even
britney
there's like a clone apparently like
they're like the real britney isn't even
here i don't know where she is but
people think that the brandy that we see
on her instagram page isn't even her
people think that about a lot of yeah a
lot of really high
high tier celebrities well they even
said that about eminem and then they
like point out
versus in his music where he talks about
like being a clone or whatever
supposedly and how he's like not even
supposed to be here
and all this stuff but yeah he's the
real deal
guys yeah he's really real still
um but yeah so uh going back to brittany
um
she has requested more freedom they
won't grant it to her
um she also like fans were saying that
there was a comment in her instagram
that was like wear
yellow tomorrow if you need help and she
wore yellow
so she just danced around she didn't
even do anything she just danced around
in yellow
yeah so a lot of fans are convinced that
she's trying to tell them things
in code and like she's not allowed to
say certain things but none of this is
proven
it's all just like conjecture and she's
even tried to tell the fans like hey
butt out like what i need right now is
space
but then she'll she says it in the
caption though you notice in the video
she's like
everything's cool i'm britney i'm barely
even here as i'm talking to you right
now she says
everything's cool guys and then
she says things that i don't even know
if she's capable of saying together in a
sentence
like in the caption yeah so it's typed
out by someone else who's controlling
that like it's the conservative
if she's not in control of her own life
is she control over instagram i doubt
that
well then people are like what is what
she has like weird projects in her
captions all the time like i'm working
on project rose right now i'm working on
project rose and then you look at
project rose and it's like some weird
thing
and then she says she's working on this
i forget the other project's names but
she
she says different projects names but
they're like code
it's like oh it seems like code because
it's like project rose project
airplane i think i saw a video of her
like dancing with a
like a hat or an umbrella or something
and she's holding it in a certain way
and her finger is pointing at like a
very small fine print
and people like zoomed in on it and it
said like help or 911 or something
seriously yeah it was all over tick-tock
man that's the kind of stuff so that's
kind of the big tease about all this
stuff is
she keeps on kind of reiterating this
need for help in some way that
at least that we all see because we're
looking for it as now too do you guys
ever see that black mirror episode with
miley cyrus
yeah it literally sounds like it it does
so there was this one episode where she
was this huge pop star
and it turns out that her aunt was
controlling her
and she just had no say in her life and
to the point where
like it seemed like she was gonna be
rebelling against the aunt and so the
aunt
drugged her put her under a coma and was
pretty much
trying to kill her and that like it was
[ __ ] crazy
but it seems like because she didn't
want to fall in line
then they had to do something to force
her to like bend at the knee
and like you you better be obedient or
else
this other [ __ ] happens and it kind of
gives me that like those vibes from the
this whole britney situation
because yeah i mean if there's like
little codes in there
little like help me like that's [ __ ]
crazy cryptic messages
speaking of kill random facts selena's
killer is getting out of prison this
year
this year yolanda my [ __ ] [ __ ] wait
what happened
angry i knew i knew what the late thing
was of course i allowed it to happen i
saw it okay i mean given i didn't do any
research but i think it was on tick tock
and people are starting a petition to
like not
i don't know she's gonna i mean she's
gonna get killed i was gonna say that
but i was like is that [ __ ] up
i really feel like she's just not gonna
make it out into the real world
she shot her so this lady yolanda she
was the
she was the fan club president president
and also like her best friend and
she was always in her circle but then it
turns out that yolanda was skimming
money
and stealing from selena and then so the
day that selena died is because she went
to go visit her in her apartment to
confront her about
this money and selena was just like you
don't have to steal like just ask and
i'll give it to you or whatever it is
and then she pretty much broke up with
her as a friend
and she was leaving and that's when
yolanda brought out a gun and shot her
in the chest
and she didn't even have a gun and then
she i don't know and then she like
locked herself in the car for many hours
as police were trying to like get her
but she was gonna kill herself and it
was
crazy dude that [ __ ] was like burned in
my memory cause i remember
like when i was little i loved selena so
much oh yeah
and like growing up after she passed
every single night i'd be praying to god
and like
talking to selena i'm like i'm so sorry
you were taking from
earth and like there's just like all
this oh okay never mind i have this
connection with her
you lying like you're lying london's
coming out no tick-tock lie to me never
mind okay
we can relax sorry sorry you mean to
tell me that not everything on
tock is true i i am just as shocked as
you are don't give up on tick tock as a
news source though
please stay open too bad eligible for
parole in 2025.
oh okay okay that's a little better but
i like the latino fire that i saw
oh yeah girl you don't my heart's racing
right now
so what are some of your theories on
this um okay so i'm of two minds about
this thing yeah cause i've
seen it from the angle of fans who
really
only see warnings only see maybe like
once they decide on narrative
they they need to see it yeah she'll see
evidence of that thing so if that's true
right
if we're all sitting here and we're like
well britney's not all there
anymore right then shouldn't she need a
conservatorship
like if we're if we're all seeing in the
evidence like she can barely
like talk to camera without seeing like
this fairy person
well one thing she does need help
picking out are her outfits
and if you need help picking out your
outfits
we got you stitch fix my god
jesus christ powerful uh no but
seriously
if you want like a personal stylist
without having to pay personal stylist
prices
you can go check out stitch fix um you
go on the website
sign up for an account and then it's a
personal styling company that brings you
the world of fashion
at your fingertips so they'll show you
different pictures of different
clothing items and you say whether or
not you like them like yay or nay
and then from that they'll assess what
your style is and then they'll send you
curated pieces in the mail you try them
on you wear them a little bit you decide
if you like them
if you like them you keep them and if
you don't like them you send them back
but you do get a discount if you keep
everything in your box uh you pay a 20
styling fee for each fixed which is like
nothing but and it's also credited
towards anything you keep
and then you can schedule it at any time
there's no subscription required plus
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free so get started today at
stitchfix.com mood and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
moon for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix
stitchfix.com mood that's right and
after you're looking so good in your new
outfits
you're going to be hungry right that's
where door doordash comes in
i always get hungry in new outfits
there's nowhere to go anymore so i dress
up just to open the door for my door
dash
you look fabulous every time you do
because i'm watching from across the
street
i don't know i got creepy but anyway so
continue supporting restaurants in your
community
safely because there are thousands of
restaurants open for delivery on
doordash that need
your patronage now more than ever so
support your favorite restaurants on
doordash
it's super easy to order all you have to
do is open up the app
choose what you want to eat and food
will be left safely outside your door
with the new contact list delivery drop
off setting
so you can support your local go to's or
you can choose your favorite national
restaurants like
chipotle wendy's and
cheesecake factory cheesecake factory
exactly
many of your local your favorite local
restaurants are still open for delivery
so go to the doordash app and get you
some delicious
food right now our listeners can get
five dollars off and zero delivery fees
on their first order of fifteen dollars
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
big mood that's five dollars off and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the door dash app
and in the app store and enter code big
mode don't forget
that's code big mood for five dollars
off your first order with
doordash okay so you think
hey maybe she does need a
conservatorship i'm seeing if there's
if there's evidence that she is reaching
out for help there's also evidence that
she
needs help with the conservatorship i
mean that's there's both sides of this
is pretty interesting
it's not just like obviously brittany
needs help
and there's a conspiracy to keep her
captured by this conservatorship thing
i think that having someone in 11 years
like
as an indentured servant is [ __ ]
weird yeah yeah and
that unless she really is like
semi-institutionalized which is the
rumor is that she
she's been put into mental institutions
a couple times so she's actually having
serious serious issues she was 51.50
right yeah she was 515. they they're
claiming that she has
she's bipolar i don't know i don't know
i mean it's not we're gonna get her
medical history you know like
there's no doctor that's gonna be like
here's what's going on with brittany and
this is all true
like we don't know like we just know
from things like that she was 5150 at
one point and so
yeah and then the other argument that
her i think her dad was giving was like
you don't understand like britney's
never
she's never experienced controlling any
of it like she doesn't know what to do
which okay but at one point none of us
had experience controlling our finances
or anything
and you kind of just like learn what to
do and if you
are an adult and you want to be
autonomous
and you're asking for it i mean she's in
a clear enough a clear enough state of
mind to request it
um i feel like i feel like it should
have been temporary i mean at least
shouldn't have lasted
this long well we also don't know or
let's
let's play with the idea of yeah she
needs it right
so then we don't know exactly how severe
her
her issues are because i think i did
hear that she has bipolar
and i i personally know someone that has
bipolar and they did have to be
institutionalized because they were just
they they were
a threat to themselves and to others and
so it can get very severe where like you
know you
this person really can't handle their
own stuff and they need help they
so who knows exactly how severe it is um
if it is the case but personally i feel
like it is really shady and there are a
lot of people to benefit out of her
to continue to stay in this conservative
that's the other part of it right where
she filed to have her own father removed
her own father also had a restraining
order put against him by her own kids
like this guy should not be the head of
the conservative if she needs it
she was requesting like okay fine but
can we have someone else
exactly yeah someone more qualified her
and her lawyer were requesting that and
they got denied it so that's where
you go okay well she does need this
because she needs help why
and she and and they claim by the way
like her father claims that
she has input on her life and all this
[ __ ] well how come she doesn't have
input on her conservative and they're
each making six figures
from this wow they're financially
incentivized to keep it going
so that's where i'm like once you give
something power i've always believed
this once you get something power
they're never gonna give it back
right look at the [ __ ] patriot act
and [ __ ] as long as they're gonna go oh
we're gonna draw down the patriot deck
now guys don't worry we feel like we
don't need it as much anymore
like they're never giving it back so
something like this is
is another example that you give them
that power they're not gonna seed it did
you see that video of her team like just
deciding every
aspect of her life no oh yeah there was
this like video
of just like kind of showing a little
portal into what goes on behind
the scenes and it's like her dad and her
team
and they're all like okay is she
available this date to work what's her
birthday should we ask her if she wants
to work on her birthday she's going to
work on her birthday
make sure she works or something i don't
remember where it was from i think it
was from this documentary that this guy
put together um because the only there
was a documentary
i think it's on youtube uh the guy put
together and um
the only thing he got like a copyright
claim against was the footage
portraying her dad in a negative light
wow yeah he's very
like that yeah about his image and he's
hates the free brittany movement
obviously
he's hired like a pr firm to battle
discredited yeah
so is there and that's what i'm here to
do has there been
um has there been any talks in
having her just retire and not not be
performing anymore or
they want that money i understand that
they there's a lot of people to make
money
obviously they're gonna want her to work
but then if it's like oh she's
she she can't handle her own
life then why not just have her stop
being a
monkey she has two kids too she has to
take care of her two kids
there's even this one i was watching a
video on it
and her kids had asked her
hey mom mommy why don't where's your
music and she goes oh i don't know baby
i don't know if i'm going to do that
anymore
yeah and her her own manager just came
out and said he doesn't know she'll even
perform again
yeah so that's why she loves performing
yeah but but we don't know
or she says she loves you yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh she does it's just that's where
it all goes crazy right or i'm like man
we don't
we don't really know brittany obviously
right we're all we all do this thing
where we're like no i do
she feels like family because we all
grew up with her of course but
you know i don't [ __ ] know brittany
but i just think that
the idea of a conservatorship there's
something so [ __ ] up about that
yeah especially when you're financially
incentivized to keep it going so
that's my end of the day take away from
this is i think that it's wrong
for her father to be the executor
because she she wants somebody else
there's a conflict of interest
number one there's abuse she she
requested someone else
and then all the kids that's a huge
thing there's not many cases
of a conservatorship lasting this long
for someone who's not
physically incapacitated yeah you know
or mentally incapacitated it's still
working so i'm like
yeah usually if they're that mentally
incapacitated to
to need a conservatorship they wouldn't
be working
or how about driving she was spotted
getting in and out and [ __ ] so
it's not like you know she can't
function that's true
so yeah there's a lot of evidence on
that yeah fame is
is wild like when you get to that level
of fame there's so many
hands in the pot there like so many
people that want a piece of it
right you know and then and they're just
grabbing i just feel like they were just
all grabbing at um
at trying to you know control aspects of
it so they get a piece of it
um the other person that's been in the
media lately
uh is paris hilton um i feel like she
kind of represents
the other spec the other end of the
spectrum on things where
she felt so controlled during childhood
um and she recently came out with a
documentary called this is paris
where she talks about it that she made
it her life's mission to never be
controlled by anything ever again
because when she was growing up she she
had all this immense pressure
to live up to the hilton name where she
would be going to
all these types of classes where she had
to learn how to be proper and elegant
and all these things
and then she hated that so much she
hated being controlled
so much that when she was a teenager she
was like you know what
[ __ ] all of this i don't give a [ __ ] she
became this party girl
and and then so the parents they ended
up feeling like oh [ __ ] we're losing
control of paris we got to do something
so they ended up sending
they ended up sending her to uh provo
county what was it called provo canyon
school kitchen
and the it's the way they did it though
it was like this school and by the way i
had
my best friend and ex-boyfriend in high
school
um both got sent away the same exact way
where they have
two big employees from the school
kidnap you in the middle of the night
like you're sleeping that's
traumatizing oh my god the whole
movement right now is like
there's a lot of trauma yeah i mean
you're a teenager you're already dealing
with all this crazy
stuff like and obviously you're acting
out for reasons
it's natural to rebel right through like
it's like throwing
throwing them away to the garbage like
okay go over there and get abused and
you should be coming back and be fixed
right
she's like i'm gonna [ __ ] take the
hilton name and make it a party palace
covered in barbie so they abducted her
in the middle of the night
and um she's like screaming she's like
mom help
like screaming for her parents to help
her and they're just like standing in
the corner trying not to look and like
crying yeah crying and stuff and then
she gets
taken away to this school where first
she goes to this wilderness camp
where they they're pretty much doing
manual labor um
she did get she she hopped around a lot
of these
these different places right yeah she
ran away from them yeah
so she ran away she got caught and then
as like a punishment they like beat the
[ __ ] out of her and her friend
in front of everybody like basically
like if you if you try to run away
this is what's going to happen to you
and i think it's legal it's in utah
so they have the least um
amount regulation around child abuse
need smoothies
i thought like in generally never mind
like gina
don't ever have kids labor laws child
abuse laws
yeah so they can get away with a lot
more in utah and that's why there's like
a concentration of these types of
schools
in utah when you got teenagers am i
right yeah well
it spawned this whole troubled teenager
industry basically
so um a couple of the survivors from
these
schools um started a movement trying to
get these schools taken away and
it started out with provo canyon but
then every couple years
some of their employees will be like
well we should start our own and so they
start their own school
and then there's just like a high
concentration of like
send your troubled teens here and we'll
take care of them
and but then while they're there they're
not telling the parents that they're
physically sexually abusing them as well
because then
paris was talking about they're heavily
medicated yeah heavily medicated as well
that she was in the solitary confinement
space
and like she'd be there i think naked
naked for 20 hours
at a time solitary confinement they just
shove you in their naked like why do you
have to be naked other than
humiliation it is it is for humiliation
because then
the one of the employees would be there
and like talking [ __ ] to them
like it was just pure humiliation
and she would hear screaming in the next
room from someone in a straight jacket
like super traumatizing she said the
only thing that kept her
sane was thinking about all the stuff
she was going to do when she
broke out of it and after she got out
she was just like i can never have my
family control me again
so that's why she went and built her
empire and she controls every single
aspect of it
she created her persona this brand of
her being dumb she's actually really
smart on audio where she's not doing the
character
yeah yeah she's pretty so intelligent in
this documentary she drops her voice
you actually see her true self and she's
so tomboy
and she's just like she's always like in
sweats or whatever like completely
different paris than what the the public
has always seen that's why i always say
like all those people the super famous
rich people that you think are dumb like
how
dumb do you think they can possibly
monroe yeah like everyone thought she
was a dumb blonde yeah she was smart as
[ __ ]
the kardashians yeah well can you
actually learn from paris
yeah she actually came out in that
documentary and said that
yeah paris was responsible for her fame
and kind of like leading was ray j like
come on man what the [ __ ] i i did
something well
actually so paris's sex tape got leaked
and that was another thing is that
um after it got leaked she got almost
even more famous but in a negative way
but she couldn't control
that and she was really mad that it got
leaked but
other people kind of saw that she was
getting all this attention from it
so then there was this this like bunch
of leaked sex
tapes that came out after that and ray j
and kim's was one of those
but hearing her talk about that whole
sex tape situation too is really
heartbreaking
yeah she was saying like you know i was
this 18 year old girl like i fell in
love
and i trusted this man and he was so
abusive
and toxic and and he pretty much like
kind of sort of forced her a little bit
like co-hearsed her
to to get filmed and she just he was
like
come on no one's going to see this and
all this [ __ ] he was calling her stupid
and yeah
he could find someone else to do it
exactly like that like manipulating her
and her trash steve
but it's almost so they did studies and
it's like
yeah if you were abused in your
childhood
you subconsciously think that that's
a normal way to live like a normal
situation to be in relationship wise
so you attract abusive relationships and
that's exactly her track record
like she even in the documentary too
they're showing scenes of
her with like the most recent guy that
she was dating and like
him being really amazing was a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah so she was actually talking about
so her relationship
is like because of the fact that she
she's
she strives to just make a lot of money
she's really motivated to be successful
and so for some reason like she needs
she can't
date someone that's on the same level as
her in terms of success and fame or
whatever it is
she she doesn't like that she'd rather
have someone who's not and but then
by that relationship she ends up being
the more powerful one and then the man
in the relationship
gets emasculated and then they can't
overcome handle it
and then they overcompensate they're
abusive towards her and then so like she
could never find the winning formula but
i don't know it seems like she's still
got a lot of
healing to do but poor girl you never
get over something like that
yeah yeah that's crazy oh and then also
the public backlash
going back to the sex tape stuff how the
entire world
were they attacked her but not yet it
was revenge porn
[ __ ] right like the dude was getting
interviewed on all these places
yeah what were they asking them they
were like um well because they were
pretty cool
they were accusing me so he was he got
to defend himself all these
places being like watch the watch the
tape man you could go watch it on my
website blah blah blah blah and like
watching and he was like he's like you
can clearly see that it's two people in
love and
while he's like marketing the sex tape
for more people to watch it yeah
yeah so [ __ ] yeah and then so but then
on the other side everyone was attacking
paris like oh you planned this
you leaked it yourself and all this [ __ ]
but imagine being in her shoes
yeah you literally trusted this man this
first love of yours or whatever you're
18 years old
you have the entire world like looking
at you
and raining down on you for you getting
abused like you had no say in the whole
world seeing you
in such an intimate light and yet it's
your fault
you have to take it that's [ __ ] up
yeah that that paris documentary
did you see it i'm not sure yet it was
really disturbing the way that her mom
and family and maybe it was just a
documentary producers
not showing us like the right clips or
whatever but it just seemed
really disturbing because um a lot of
her
the way she acts is because of this
trauma that happened
when she was a teenager and they're not
reading it as
as that as a symptom of trauma they're
reading it as like oh she's just being a
drama queen like she's being dramatic
like there was one part where nikki
helton was talking about her being
super dramatic because like she's always
got like she always oh my god there's
another one that's right nikki
yeah holy crap i forgot sorry um and and
like there's a scene where
um she paris forgot her sunglasses and
she's like oh my god can i go get my
sunglasses really quick they're on the
table and she's like no we don't have
time
and paris was like no i really need them
i really need them and it's almost like
her security link
having like different sunglasses is kind
of like her thing and it's almost like
she's hiding from the world and
everyone's just getting pissed at her
thinking that she's being a drama queen
it's not that big of a deal and she says
sorry a bunch after um
so it really disturbed me like those
like little things like that like and
also the mom's reaction once paris
finally
like showed her some photos of like of
that movement that the pro
provo what place whatever all the
survivors were
they had like these signs and they wrote
down like all the [ __ ] that they
experienced like sexual abuse ptsd like
eating disorders whatever it is that
they ended up getting out of this trauma
and the mom was just like what
but it was just like yeah she didn't
react no empathy really
yeah and maybe you know people process
empathy different maybe she knew she was
on camera and she didn't want to
like cry or whatever i don't know i like
to get better for the doubt
but um anyway if you have bad habits
then
[Music]
peris hilton's mom listen uh unhealthy
ways of pressing things
no um noom is an app that is a healthy
habit weight loss
app um but i feel like it's not just for
weight loss because a lot of times you
think of an app for weight loss and it's
like counting calories and
uh doing a food diary and um exercising
more than you eat or burning up in the
morning waking up brushing your teeth
surviving but this is more focused on
like the psychological aspects of why
you might not be
hitting your goals so with noom you have
certain goals like let's say mine was to
lose some weight that could be one of
them um they will
like like take a take a look at your
habits that are maybe contributing to
you overeating like not just the
overeating itself but
maybe you tend to overeat in social
situations or maybe you tend to
overeat when you have anxiety or a
stress and you kind of work on
acknowledging those habits and then
breaking those and then the weight loss
is kind of like um
the end result that happens after
dealing with the internal stuff so i
really like that
it's got ease and convenience you just
do 10 minutes a day the tone of the
program works with your lifestyle
and you don't have to commit to a
rigorous plan it's based in psychology
it's based on cognitive behavioral
approach and uses personalized courses
to help you reach your specific goals
over 80 percent of numerous finish the
program and over 60 percent have stuck
with their goals for at least one year
so high success rate there's a science
to getting healthier and it's called
noom
sign up for your trial today at
noomnoom.com
big mood what do you have to lose visit
noom.com
big mood to start your trial today
that's noomnoom.com
big mood yeah and i want to talk about
fab
fit fun oh my god i love it so much i
know i so
i just recently received my very first
box ever and so i have always seen
people promoting this on social media
and i'm always like oh man i really want
to try it and so finally thank you
fabfitfun you guys sent us
our fall box and in this fall box there
were so many
good things that i actually ended up
keeping all of them because i was
thinking i'm like well if there's some
some stuff here and there that might not
really fit with my taste or whatever it
is because
i have i'm brand new to this maybe i can
save it for a gift or something because
they're full-size products
they're not like sample size little
things
but i mean it works i would do the same
thing honestly like if i didn't want
something i would just gift it too
imagine we just give it to each other
like hey
i mean he's like i got this too exactly
i got the fabfitfun box too [ __ ] we all
have the same stuff
it's good stuff though i know so my
purse that i've been
using recently i forgot the brand but
it's this like really cute black
backpack purse yeah backpackers yeah
exactly and i even
got it i have it and i i bring it with
me every single day
i absolutely love it so yeah i feel like
the value of this box is so amazing
because like i said you get full size
products they're quality stuff
name brand stuff and it's just like
why not treat yourself every season you
know so it's time to customize your box
for the fall season sign
up today to receive your first box and
join a community of over one million
women
who are already obsessed and i'm one of
these millions
i love it uh use coupon code big mood
for ten dollars off your first box at
fabfitfun.com that's code
big mood for 10 off your first box at
fabfitfun.com let me know what you think
yeah so paris is actually a boss ass
businesswoman um
did you like think of her that way when
uh well i
i am i kind of go against the grain a
lot when it comes to
when everybody's trying to tell me yeah
this is how somebody is yes i'm always
like i don't know maybe i should try to
look for something else steve hitler was
really bad everyone thinks so i think
they're maybe
wrong no but that's
no i mean obviously there's some easy
ones yeah but but
anytime that it's like harmless right
where it's like
okay so so this celebrity person is a
ditz she's so dumb
oh my god paris like you're all about
the shoes like i don't know man i always
i just don't think that anything's that
simple especially when somebody's being
outwardly portrayed like that yeah it's
like when you're being advertised too
honestly yeah it's like did you know
that periscope is like this
did you know that periscope is like this
do you know the perishables like this
and you're constantly getting inundated
with it
and that's what always makes me
skeptical because i think everyone gets
like mislabeled something just by being
in public or ever being on camera
somehow
i think it's so dumb when people just
take it and just take it as
face value yeah without doing a little
bit of critical thinking like i said
earlier
she's rich as [ __ ] right and she's well
a lot of people wrote that off as like
well she has like
money i mean her family gave her the
money right didn't her grandfather cut
her off
if he said that if she doesn't stop
[ __ ] up he'll cut her off but
like besides that but also like the
kardashians i [ __ ] look listen man i
don't keep up with them
their branding is just so good it's like
innately in you see that i didn't
um or like when people get all all up in
arms about well they just did this and
it's terrible and
and it's all over i'm like you do
realize that that's what they want
right they're so smart because how long
are people have like
they've been still talking about them
did they accept my dreams
yeah i literally don't follow any of
them either and
somehow kylie's always popping up in my
dreams
i knew i know things about them that i
don't care to know but it's because
they're so good so
when you're if you're if you're looking
at this and you're still thinking these
people are so
dumb and they have no talent like you
are an idiot you're the dumb one like
this is
amazing yeah it's worked by them half of
their
money is coming from haters yeah right
yeah and they're monetizing their haters
so that's the thing
they just don't people don't understand
how that stuff works sometimes and also
too
being like a social media person i've
been on both sides of the fence where i
see how someone's portrayed and i know
them in real life yeah everyone thinks
i'm a hoe
but that's the thing right so once you
know that once you see how everyone says
something and then you actually
know how it is you can never go back
from that yeah like i will read things
about social media people
in newspapers that is not real or true
or even just about the amount of money
we all make it's all [ __ ]
like yeah like all the all the stuff
that they say that we
do when i look when you actually know
the person you're like
man i you've got this so wrong it's
crazy i know and then sometimes i wonder
too i'm like wait
how did you get all the information that
was given to you
and then distort it to create something
that's not even true anymore
that should be so that's why i think
paris is so smart because she thought
about branding from the beginning
like she thought of herself as a brand
she was actually
what was that show she was on with nikki
uh simple life simple life
she was actually considered the original
influencer because she
started like the famous for being famous
type of thing
but she always thought of herself as in
terms of a brand like
is this an alignment with my brand will
this hurt my brand so she branded
herself
and no one else could like she branded
herself dumb and ditzy
and whatever do you remember when
everyone's like that's hot yeah
yeah so hot she tried to trademark it
the sunglasses the pink the poodle
everything it was fantastic so when
other people are allowed to dictate your
branding or what they're perceiving you
as that just tells me that like we maybe
weren't as good as
a branding ourselves yeah yeah or using
it to win
yeah that's what she did she's like i'll
use the inertia of all this [ __ ] to
[ __ ] make myself
a [ __ ] independent empire yeah
there's a lot of those now like even on
youtube or instagram where you just see
them it's like god
like some people just go crazy and do
stupid things they're just out of their
minds and you realize they're making so
much money off of this
oh my god it's incredible that's why she
says she thinks she created a monster
yeah yeah like we we know one person
but i remember i asked you guys like is
she [ __ ] insane you guys when you
guys are like yes and she's making so
much money off of it that's correct
yeah i know exactly yeah mm-hmm damn it
yeah and people don't even know that we
know them either so
oh that's always i see i see so
everyone's gonna start like in the
comments uh
the one you said like yeah she's crazy
but she knows what she's doing crazy oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot of people like
that yeah exactly
so i mean it's a winning formula
apparently it's working because at the
end of the day that's a lot of money in
your bank man that's a lot of doll hairs
that's a lot of [ __ ] dollars and i
love doll hairs
it works and with that is the
independence to do whatever the [ __ ] you
want
like paris hilton could just walk away
which she kind of has lately like she's
kind of not been in the spotlight she's
also been on set up lately god i need to
get off that app so bad yeah well she
doesn't take a vacation she like she
says
some she works like 250 she's traveling
250 days of the year
and she actually suffers from insomnia
so she'll sleep like two hours
because she has nightmares about this
school every single
night jesus yeah what what is she what
is she doing now like what is she doing
she's a dj
she travels she has i forgot how many
brands but just 19 brands yeah something
like that
that's what i said in the document but
notice how her brand is not
now skewered to being the top of the
tabloids and all that stuff right right
she's gone from all that [ __ ] she's like
she has perfume
like apparel i don't know anyone that
wears or buys anything paris hilton
though like that name was huge
back then yeah no yeah nowadays it's
like what is she doing exactly
if paris someone walked into a room like
everyone would be like holy [ __ ] it's
very hilton right
yeah you know a few years ago um i had
heard
about her persona being just
a fake persona and not really herself
and that
in reality she is this like brilliant
woman and she created this whole image
for her
and i heard this years ago and i'm like
nah really
yeah i don't know i must i'm very
simple-minded nikki i believe whatever
you push in front of my face i'm very
gullible
i mean i look at the hitler thing yeah
on the hitler i look at numbers so if
you're like you know
hey you know she's not really dumb she
actually built this many businesses has
this much in revenue a year and this
much blah blah blah i'm like oh yeah she
hella smart
yeah like the smartest people are not
the ones that
know all the things like do are doing
all the math the smart people are the
ones leveraging
themselves simple-minded ones end up
going but that's not even her she's just
a puppet then because she's already come
she came from money she has a hilton
name so obviously she didn't do this on
her own
that's what i used to think that's what
i noticed about this britney spears
thing is um
one of the one of the people who was
commenting on this one one youtube
person was saying that
obviously britney can't be um
have dementia because she won a lot of
vmas that
year yeah and i was like i'm not that
simple how in the [ __ ] did you get there
man
my brain just having a stroke i'm like
bro like i i don't know where i don't
know how you got there
i need you to walk me through this
because i am so curious as to how you
got there so
when she goes into her therapist office
they're like well how many vmas did you
win this year
uh well i won five no you're not you're
good she's holding her vmas
i don't know where i am right now but
look at these things you got five people
no you're good mentally stable as [ __ ]
yeah that's what i mean by when you
okay so if and and people you know this
video had very nice like to dislike
ratio i think a lot of people were like
yeah that's really true and
i just it saddens me because i wish
people just
looked a little deeper at the actual
argument that's being presented right
britney spears is being held captive by
her estate
fact she tried to push her father out
that's another fact
like is she does she seem like she's
crying out for help
it seems like it we don't know but like
i i but instead of like just
taking the the fact that the fat or the
dish that's served right in front of you
and eating all of it like just take a
look at your food first
well i i have now because now i've
surrounded myself with very intelligent
friends
which now might mentality i'm always
skeptical now
critical thinking right now question
everything but old tiff
she was so simple it can go too far the
other way too where you're like
wait everything's alive yeah and then
everything
and that's when people become like very
intimidating
you guys are all such sheep yeah i'm
smarter than everyone because that's
those words free the free the sheeple we
the people of the wake up everyone
wake up sheeple yeah yeah and i used to
be like i could be a sheep it's okay
well you would be like these people are
pretty well cared for
yeah i'm like you don't have to think
it's cool they have a purpose
they make wool they keep little warm see
that they have a purpose it's fine they
make ugg boots
and we all need ugg boots so is paris
hilton not
in contact with her parents or anything
anymore is she just
she is she is she yeah she is but she
just
she never told them any of this
beforehand like oh
yeah she just used it as a as her
fuel too for her yeah good for her to
get become successful
yeah you think you're swimming she
[ __ ] swam the [ __ ] out of that yeah
she is an olympic size pool
yeah um and then so what where where is
britney spears's mom
so that's what's interesting too is that
certain tweets that
that are like free brittany her mom has
liked them
oh wait her mom's active oh i thought
she was oh she's alive and she's like
tweets where they say she's in a mental
institution and stuff so she's like
giving some juice to all this
yeah and well her and the dad are
supporters
of course wait who what her and her
britney spears and the
and the mom their mom and dad are
divorced yeah
yeah because i remember there was also
some drama with the mom
and like she would be fighting with
brittany a lot and it was like some sort
of like that
i don't remember but that makes sense to
me why she wouldn't be one of the
conservators [ __ ] i heard a theory where
because you know how like jamie lynn
spears on nickelodeon all that stuff
you know like the creative nickelodeon's
like a huge pedo that has a huge foot
fetish yes
like there's back then well he was was
he the creator at the time or i don't
know if he was crazy
he was in charge he was like the guy
yeah dude he had like a weird foot
fetish have you seen like videos of
ariana grande back then like
the things he made her do like what like
um like putting her feet in her mouth
yeah
and like she has a huge foot fetish like
it was played off how did she do that
i mean like how did he work into
did you guys know that some people can
can't put their foot in their mouth
well i can watch this and then or like
she's like squeezing a
a potato she's like i wonder if i can
juice a potato
ah like like just really creepy [ __ ] or
like dumping water in her mouth like
really creepy
so jamie lynn spears was a part of the
whole nickelodeon thing at the time
and she was a teen mother and people
were saying that um
it could have been that guy's kid no way
like he was yeah like statutory rape or
something and that's why she disappeared
and stuff
wait so the father never is not publicly
known
uh i i don't know i guess not but people
are saying his boyfriend at the time
but i mean you have to take up a
parental test
yeah fraternity i gotta show you that
video it's really disturbing like just
you notice all the
feet the nickelodeon logo is a giant
foot
oh yeah yeah all right yeah yeah and
they're like all these um all these
shows
like those what are those shows back
then on
like um or like later or later years but
there was always like something about
feet like their feet were always showing
and stuff like that it was really crazy
and by the way people that have foot
fetishes we're not gonna yuck they're
and i don't want to know the arguments
for furries [ __ ] you i don't care
i'm not eating it but now i wonder like
where is jamie lynn spears where
like where's the mom and stuff like that
apparently she hasn't touched the
diamond britney's money that's what she
says that's good yeah
she's like what the brother has hasn't
he yeah the brother was in
like was defending the dad oh no yeah
um there's certain things you don't know
and stuff like that
duh we want to know man tell us right
and then brittany herself was like hey i
know you guys love me and i really
appreciate it but like
the biggest thing you can do to help me
right now is just give me space
so uh and then oh and jamie lynn did say
um like hey you don't know my sister
she's actually really really strong and
she's
fighting she's a fighter just like let's
she's fighting
what is she fighting exactly if she
didn't have something to fight then
why it could be with herself or
something who knows but there's there's
also
all these child stars like uh aaron
carter oh man he lost his
recently saw mind concert with aaron
carter there i didn't mean to be there
but i was there i like how you like
offended oh i didn't mean to be there
with him but yeah
no we were at this party this was like a
year yeah no it was like
three or four we weren't married um oh
yeah it
it was 2016. i'm sorry i remember dates
so well
uh it was junior every time we do that
i'm like wow it was because it's like
it's associated with vidcon and i'm like
okay well that was the last year we were
at vidcon it was 2016.
oh right we went to the party yeah yeah
so we just show up and we're eating food
and then all of a sudden aaron carter's
just doing a set
and we're like what the [ __ ] did he look
like a crackhead he looked like
yeah i mean he looked like he was like
walking out of a gas station with a tall
boy
yeah yeah okay well he's defended
himself that he's
he hasn't done drugs um but he actually
suffered from like an eating disorder
or something i remember that he was an
only fans
what he had the only fans just just said
that you said he does
but that's how he beat shaq oh my god
that's right and i want candy
remember that song dude he did check
because you know what shaq's doing gold
bond and he and he's got a jerking on
camp
what so shaq is shaq has so many
companies i love that man i think shaq
one is one of those yeah
are you sure aaron carter didn't beat
jack
there's some arguments to be made okay
well tbd or like there was like videos
of
of aaron carter just going off on a
weird rant and then kissing his mom on
the mouth or something like that too i
remember that like
wow yeah it was pretty crazy he's poor
child what are your final thoughts on
this brittany
okay i think that we got to free
brittany because i think that it's wrong
oh so you are on the free britney side
yeah because you did a lot of devil's
advocate on the other side i try to do
both
but i i personally just don't think that
the idea of a conservatorship especially
something that was supposed to be
temporary
should have people who are financially
incentivized to keep you in it
yeah it makes no [ __ ] sense at all uh
paris
hilton i [ __ ] love you always been a
fan
i always knew you were a smart chick but
i didn't know how
smart or how she was smart how she was
smart how she was i didn't know in what
way she was smart but i knew that she
was doing smart things but i didn't
really know
what got it got it flat
other than turning a bunch of attention
on herself for years
being in [ __ ] every commercial at the
time she was in movies just to say
that's hot as a cameo real quick like
she [ __ ] killed it at that
yeah she knew her branding no credit and
i like the way you know what you're
right she was
the first influencer how wild is that
that's what they say in the documentary
so cool
nobody was taking selfies before her but
if you remember every one of the time
all the people who the media media
critics and
like conservative groups and stuff they
were all saying uh
well this is going to be the downfall of
society now now you have somebody who's
famous for being famous
and didn't that happen that is true oh
nailed that that was a [ __ ] jump shot
random fact i totally forgot to point
out uh paris hilton
if you notice on her instagram even her
still photos they're actually videos
like still videos
so that every time someone scrolls past
it it's it marks as a view
so instead of getting likes it shows the
numbers of views instead which is
exponentially higher so like instead of
she should like because you know your
your
instagram video it shows numbers of
views instead of like yeah so
all of her stills are actual loop videos
so people are like that's genius it
makes her numbers look
huge she's really ahead of her so smart
as far as
the social media branding all of that
stuff um well anyway let us know your
thoughts in the comments do you want to
free brittany do you think pair do you
has your mind changed about paris
paris hilton let us know nah she's just
a dumb [ __ ]
good for you also rate us five stars on
itunes we love it it helps us out a lot
also like our video that helps us on
youtube
a lot with that dumb algorithm thing
yeah also i would like to plug my show
[ __ ] they don't tell you
you should watch it they don't tell you
it's a great podcast
it's our chief competitor that's our
chief competitor i'm happy to be on the
show finally promoting my thing it's my
product
i was on the i was on the show once that
episode's probably the best episode
they've ever done in their
good the most amount of views it was
also like orgies and threesomes or
something like that yeah
but gina can't stop sucking dicks with
the tongue yeah yeah yeah there you go
there you go cause her branding is the
biggest hoe you know so
anyway we'll see you next time bye